happy anniversary
hello
welcome to uh new rock stars doing a
live stream we don't know how it
happened we don't know why it's
happening but it's happening happy 4 20
everybody
uh we are drinking uh our own uh elixirs
here don't ask what's in them um
but smoke them if you got them but uh
just some some information about what's
happening here we are doing a uh live
discussion slash reaction to what was
the most insane episode we could have
possibly gotten for moon night we had
some hot takes we thought were gonna
happen and instead they were just like
no you guys are all stupid uh this whole
thing just got blown open so we figured
we would go live uh and play a little
bit of uh play around with you guys and
like figure out what you guys think
figure out what our co-workers here
think we are literally in our actual
break room at our new rockstar's office
on the moon
but also uh we're going to actually play
around with some live elements too so
there's going to be some little things
you guys can activate hey look see
you're seeing things are popping up uh
there's a little like glass here that
you can fill with liquor uh and then
down here there's all of our newest
subscribers but uh some other things you
guys can do if you guys use super chats
we're going to collect those super chats
for any questions we're going to throw
them to the end of the show
we're going to get to as many of those
as we can for a q a segment but also if
you guys want to use um some stickers uh
we specifically are going to request
that you guys use the hippo stickers and
you know why if you watch the episode uh
the hippo stickers uh if you use if you
type in the chat exclamation point live
it'll give you an explanation of kind of
which stickers can trigger some things
on uh the broadcast here i've been
talking a long time so i'm going to
introduce you guys to who else is here
uh we got zach huddleston hello good to
be here good to hang out with everybody
also spoiler warning if you guys yeah
yeah yeah
and we all are doing our uh uh
catchphrases that was zach's spoiler
warning
and tommy bechtel
chatting with my friends that sounds
gucci the moochie stop saying that
to get guccifuchi happen oh well
i'll throw a gucci tamuchi in the chat
if you want to win a chance to win a
grand prize from me which is just uh
i'll pay your cell phone bill for it
that's a good deal
does that include the cell phone itself
because
it's just a bill in one week so you've
got data it's cut quarterly
and it's got to be a burner phone
and it's got to be pre-paid
let us know if uh tommy's already paying
your cell phone bill he's got a lot of
people out there that he's covering uh
oh and thank you mezzo jd for doing an
announcement in the discord uh and let's
go ahead and get started uh about like
what this insane episode might have been
telling us so our first question here is
this is a theory that we saw uh this is
showing up on twitter some people
already left his comment on the reaction
that we posted earlier
uh the well we're gonna jump to the
insane end of the episode uh without
spoiling it if in case you just jumped
on or whatever the crazy location we end
up at the end of the episode here's a
question that's been asked to us is that
the afterlife could it be
now the thing we last saw right before
is he had mark slash steven had just
been shot twice and then theoretically
drowned
and then we end up in this very unusual
location is it the afterlife
think um i i think this episode follows
a lot of the jeff lemire uh ish running
of moon knight which is spectacular if
you guys haven't read any moonlight
please start with the jeff lemirons it's
crazy the art is beautiful but it starts
with mark getting shot and winding up in
this psych ward that is actually the
overvoid so i do think this is like some
form of the afterlife but i do think the
psych ward is within the overvoid where
all the gods are currently define
overboys
i think maybe at the first meeting of
the ad right the overvoid is where all
the gods are currently and they can
possess their avatars from there so and
it possesses not a good word but it's
where they can they all go
that's their home and then the avatars
stay on earth where they can just
communicate that way interesting so you
think it's the overboard
because that would give reason to why
we're already seeing i'm gonna say since
we're probably gonna talk to it later
the hippo lady
towel rat
i think how we're trying to say we're
trying to say
yeah a towel rat towel rat yes uh worst
thing to find when you draw yourself at
the gym
what gym you go to
you go to cheesers my gym the rats are
great they're very preoccupied
they're animatronic there right
the gym that has the ball pit and the
video games and the giant stuff
i don't think you're saying it correctly
it's jesus yeah i try to get my pumps in
i do think it's the afterlife i think
this and i think the mcu is going to
establish this thing where
wherever you die determines the type of
afterlife you get because there's all
these different gods right in the mcu
all these different like celestial
beings all these different religions
that people celebrate practice but if
you die in a certain area i think that
determines where you go i think he did
die and he falls into that little pool
yeah what must be the grossest water i
was going to say how that water has to
be enchanted
because it's just disgusting inherently
blessed well tommy thinks old water's
always been chanting yeah
i mean i remember our swimming pool we
would never change it year to year and
my dad would say jump in the enchanted
pool yeah yeah yeah
you're covered in slime he's got
santeria glasses all around here
but that one did not appear to be like
murky or appear to be very clear so
either someone had freshly filled it or
something had freshly filled it or
it's enchanted water yeah there's a
filter i mean it's in the desert could
be filtered down through the limestone
of these cave type structures i i like
that idea brandon but i'm gonna say it's
not the afterlife
though it is like that journey between
when you die and when you walk all the
way towards the light it feels like this
asylum location is that distance right
between
you know starting to die and being fully
dead
yeah
yeah or maybe like kind of a coma-like
state something like that only because
eric in the new rockstars breakdown that
just came out a little over an hour ago
i'm sure everybody in the chat has
already watched it but
he pointed out like could be a parallel
to the wizard of oz
dorothy scenario right she falls and
hits her head and then imagines kind of
the entire oz thing placing people she
knew in her real life into this kind of
like imaginary world and it seems like
that's kind of what we're getting maybe
here
interesting uh also real quick i'm gonna
uh point out something i didn't point
out earlier
we have a uh
thing we're gonna try to do here uh as
the super chats fill up i'm not sure i
can't see uh what it's at right now kind
of what what's it at right now
oh we already did it all right wow so
we'll explain it uh uh who let's pick uh
let's say tommy uh tommy's gonna
illustrate this for us uh whenever we
hit fifty dollars uh if with our super
chats one person is going to become uh
basically replaced by their their statue
version of themselves we're gonna trap
we're gonna trap them in their uh who's
shorty uh
what shorty uh and then uh they're gonna
have to speak to us from their oh shorty
uh tommy is that okay with you
tommy stop eating
[Music]
i'm ready i'm ready to speak from the
beyond don't tell mark to free me tell
me
do you think it's uh the overvoid do you
think it's the afterlife well here's my
question does he still have the statue
of ammit on him because i'm wondering if
there's some power from the statue that
is putting him in a
100 i was thinking about that i think
it's a little too vague tommy look at me
tommy look at me i think it's a little
too you're not looking eyes up here
tommy eyes up here and saw me eyes
[Laughter]
i was also thinking about that too
because we see in the in the show that
it's like it's out of his hands rapidly
so either he gave it to layla or he put
it in his pocket but i think that's
already like a sign that ahmed's been
kind of released yeah
right tommy and ahmed is ultimately who
decides who gets to like pass on to the
uh
to a rewarding afterlife or a upon over
after life of punishment yes yeah
because the psych ward is even maybe a
little bit of vomit's playground
i think that's what i was
holding on to i i'm riding this roller
coaster that it is the jeff lemire run
of moon knight and nothing else but i'm
like okay so if they did release ahmet
right now by accident or on purpose or
whatever
going through the water that could mean
in the comic emmett was actually the
doctor the physician that was working
over moon knight working over mark and
stephen so what if ahmed is already
within arthur hero in this void and this
and we're just like he's just talking to
ahmed right now because him and ahmed
the things that arthur harrow was saying
was a little too like
godly if you will by the way this theory
has been officially eric boss approved i
don't know if you guys saw that
okay not eric in the chat we now have a
uh redemption where it's just eric boss
approved okay
he does also i think that's a good way
to grant tommy the corporeal form again
oh gross
what i missed guys
the whole time i just want to point out
that statue tommy was way more salient
in
and real quick can we uh make sure that
we are updating the donation level that
we see in our notes here so we can keep
track of when that redemption happens
please and thank you thank you to dodson
down there and shout out olivia i know i
you are one of the the super chat givers
there thank you so much yes and also
very quick uh for those of you wondering
where eric voss is he lives in san
francisco and our office is not in san
francisco unfortunately
it's on the moon as i said earlier uh
also eric does so much you guys can't
demand that much of the poor man he is
currently oh there he is i approve
nothing he is currently pumping out so
much content for you guys working so
hard this is an example of a way that we
can just give him a little bit of room
and let him do his own thing if anybody
else asks uh uh where's eric boss if you
guys can do us a favor of answering that
answer that i just gave and also i think
we would all agree that eric voss is
always right here that's right yes
mitch sternum yeah
where is your heart again
that's your belly button tommy
brandon has thoughts well my thought is
this if whatever is happening to mark
steven right now all these other people
that we see in the psych ward are they
just manifestations from his own mind
are they projections like none of them
are actually there like arthur harrow's
not there whatever is happening is being
drawn out of his own mind in a weird way
no one else is actually there i could
see that especially because like if
you're inside your own dreams dreams are
isn't that like a theory that dreams are
the people you see in your gyms are
people you've seen in real life so that
would make sense that if he's inside his
own mind all the people that he's seeing
are the people that he's met before or
or inside his own mind or are you about
to call out
haunted autumn just kind of pointed out
uh thank you for the super chat i think
they are on the way to the underworld on
that giant ship from the trailers and
he's been dead the whole time and he's
been dead the whole time the little girl
in the museum the very first episode was
like are you pissed that you got
rejected from the sea of reeds or
whatever and he's like no what do you
mean for that to happen i'd have to
already be dead so it's like a river
stick situation so you're saying that
everything we've seen in the show
episodes one through four he's been dead
the whole time i think i like that
answer because like let's all be honest
the this was all a dream this was all in
mark's head
is an unsatisfying answer we don't want
that to be true so i like that answer
because like the series all really
happened he just is some kind of weird
half ghost half man
ghostwritery living dead man kind of
thing so layla going to the forger at
the beginning of episode three in order
to make her way to cairo
that
happened because mark's not there at all
to like
be uh the audience's like avatar if you
will to show us that like this is all
happening in his head good point that
happens for real or like when we see
arthur harrell like preparing himself at
the beginning
in the afterlife
you know which is how tommy gets into
heaven
yeah the first shoe glasses uh scene
there's nothing
we haven't even met him yet yeah so it's
like if this were on his mind why would
he be picturing scenes that he's not
even is this all in arthur harrow's mind
because he got drunk he put glass in his
shoes because he's a drunk he doesn't
know what he's doing and now he's just
imagining he's trying to sell a
screenplay wait is the water that arthur
herrera with the clear liquid oh
drinks in the first episode the water
that well they haven't been able to find
the tomb yet so i don't think it is
right well what if he had already been
gifted some of the water these are the
kind of questions we're gonna answer
later in the
q a
let's go let's go ahead and move on to
our next question this is my favorite uh
moment so as we're setting up at the end
of the episode and we've got the two
versions we got mark and steven standing
next to each other and they're uh
checking in a doorway and there's a
sarcophagus there and it starts twerking
violently uh
what does that mean who might be in that
sarcophagus what do you guys think
that's that third altar right it's got
to be i also love it standing up whereas
steven was in a laying down sarcophagus
that's usually how those are presented
this is more aggressive this this
sarcophagus is like ready to rumble
already
it doesn't harkens back to that
sarcophagus we saw with the little girl
in the first episode when he points it
out and shows a standing sarcophagus in
the museum
after they were just at the little great
pyramid model and he was like well
there's nothing in there anyways or she
says there's nothing in there anyways
question for the chat just somebody can
look this up or something or might know
i know chrissy knows a lot about uh just
like egyptology i think
she usually is but maybe not uh but uh
is is there a difference in their uh
decisions in ancient egypt of when they
sometimes have them laying down and
sometimes have them standing up yeah i
wonder if there's already significance
to that oh i don't know i thought i just
assumed which is horrible um that he
knocked himself over
like whoa
he's shaking to get out but when we see
alexander's team it's it's that laying
down no it definitely is yeah so there's
got to be a difference i think i think
you're onto something because this is i
do not read too much in this but it is
known that like the guards the like uh
the guards of the gods or
the king's tombs they are the ones
standing up against the walls where the
gods are the ones or the kings are the
ones laying down yeah i feel like the
topic is standing up is like a museum
thing right i would assume in most
it's usually lane i would assume
yeah and there's structure it's top
hated as well
here's who's in the sarcophagus in the
asylum okay it's mumrah we're about to
make the leap to thundercats yeah get
out of here
that is a garbage answer you can say
garbage
i'll do nothing let me see the chat for
brandon's credibility somebody in the
chat said that it could be layla's
father the red scarab i think that would
be okay
we did see the little red scarab on the
band-aid and there's been so much scarab
talk this whole season yeah now we're
not even talking about jake luckily yet
it seems too easy right
look at the room they're in so clear if
there is different
if there's difference
sarcophagus with sarcophagi in different
rooms
in different wombs that means there's
different personalities that we already
haven't seen and different runs he's
more than just jake and mark and steven
there's more to them so i'm
i mean we want to see it be jake but
watch it be just someone else well
that's what anybody marveling
an identity yeah a different identity no
yes an identity yes enough okay
jake locke
is that what you're saying well she's
someone else i don't know if you mean
like a different actor even yeah oh no
no no no no no they're all they're all
oscar isaac different different
identities
uh something's uh something's happening
uh
we're waiting for the typing to finish
here
oh what everybody or
or just well we did we do have a uh
upper level where if we cleared it
everybody gets replaced by their
clearances i think we did clear because
we were at like 40.
uh do we know
i'm yelling
i'll just do it yeah if you guys if you
guys wouldn't mind sending some uh
egyptian juju my way
i don't know if this is okay
it's the fact that he said juju
zach can you defend yourself you said
egyptian juju what did you mean i
apologize if that was an appropriation
for vinegar
oh my gosh
calm down
you don't appropriate i inappropriately
i haven't charged here
why do you keep holding us can i can i
see this on camera better
can i offer a theory that i have
oh god under at gunpoint if if it is
jake lockley is jake lockley perhaps
like just impersonating mark and stephen
at different times and that's why the
security guard calls him simon or
whatever it is because jake lockley
can't even be bothered to remember
stephen
exactly somebody asked that bird out on
a steak day
i love that theory also that security
guard did not show up in the asylum you
saw stephen's boss we saw a lot of
characters from stephen's life we saw
the uh the gold man yeah uh but we did
not see that security guard that's
interesting
to bring it right back to bring it back
again to the jeff lemire comic because
i'm addicted um those guards were like
the jackals and i loved that i held on
to it because i was like oh this black
and white man are the jackals and
they're
protecting ahmet and then they are
mirrored perfectly in this episode so i
think they're just jackal guards i don't
think they're just jackal guards i don't
think they're good people
all right well hey you know what
you have an opinion and we can think
it's wrong what no
can i ask a question of my own yeah you
may you just need to submit it via super
chat okay uh i don't have any money in
my bank account right now uh
who is the hippo
okay tower right uh this is uh the last
thing we see in the episode right uh and
uh brandon says towel rat uh brandon why
don't you explain what that means well
uh tauret is the goddess of fertility uh
in egyptian mythology and she is one of
the aeneid in both egyptian mythology
and in marvel comics she's one of those
that crosses over we saw the little
hippo plushies in the first episode uh
and now we see her here the there's an
actress i forget her name now uh who's
been credited with the voice of tara and
imdb says will be in the next two
episodes angelo
it's very it is very interesting to
introduce this new god that
it's kind of like out of left field
we're like what is this not to do with
it the most interesting thing i think is
i re watching some episodes in the first
episode when mark wakes up on the bus
there is a pregnant woman on that bus
standing there like center frame in the
camera and i'm like i don't know what if
this has anything to do with it if this
is part of it or not i don't know but it
is interesting to see this goddess
appear uh and be like in a very almost
american sounding accent be like
how you doing
that high-pitched voice just squirted
out exactly yeah i'm sorry i did i just
jump into your frame as well brandon
yeah that's how everything works
sometimes that's how juju works
no you can't you can't use that one but
you know we at the very beginning of
this episode too right we saw osiris put
the
ushati of khanshu on a shelf with like
nine other ones standing around so it
was hard to make out all of them but
like tara is maybe one of those also
because she was not at the the trial
that we had she's only like five of them
yeah she's not at the trial but she's in
the museum
um
yeah she's the pleasure
and we saw her statue in the
piece of gear i i was just gonna say
this is the first time so the only gods
we've physically seen not their avatars
but actually god we've seen khan shu
though that's only presumably in stephen
and mark's mind right right so far yeah
and now
right we haven't seen any other
physicalizations of a god so like does
that mean that like is one of them also
being an avatar of tower rat and that's
why they're seeing her or is this this
white asylum place like gods can wander
freely which is overvoid right yeah uh
all uh i have a question unless there's
more to zach's answer yeah uh is
why have this uh god that was not part
of the the any ad show up is this
somebody who's gonna be a new ally is
this somebody who is gonna like what is
the point of adding this this new god
more gods
will come out in the they're in the
overvoid so more gods can wander as is
but i think being the god of fertility
or like childbirth and what have you is
a big component of death uh does that
make sense we have mark right now that
just got shot and is either dead or
something and i think a full circle is
you need her for that
i feel like that god is still needed in
one way and she's trying to help also
communion with god upon death seems like
a really like interesting
that moment is so pivotal in someone's
life that you do have an interaction
with the god that's interesting i'm
definitely i'm definitely getting ally
vibes not enemy vibes because also
hippos can be frightening creatures they
chose they chose to make this hippo
kind of friendly and maybe a little
silly look and so like that means
part hippo the lower half right yeah the
back half somebody has a really
interesting point uh
i think i i missed it maybe come back
but somebody was uh pointing out that in
the d.i.d uh
i guess i was saying psychology that
sometimes there is an internal kind of
uh space like a sanctum that the
identities can reside in like the mind
palace kind of thing so then that would
say it is just inside his mind and we
are we are wandering within within the
mind and then so are the gods
if they're also there or at least the
hippo got it the hippo god is there
but that would also make sense one of
these one of these characters is an
expert in egyptology so maybe even just
in their little mind palace they would
have some manifestations of egyptian
gods right
uh somebody else also asked how you
submit questions uh again we're going to
do a q a section at the end of this but
we do it uh any super chats that we get
that are questions we're gonna get to as
many of those as we can otherwise we'll
try to keep an eye out we're shoving all
your questions down alexander the
great's throat and we're gonna pull him
out later
speaking of that we've had some massive
uh plumbing issues today and
uh it's just very funny to us that we uh
we we're gonna go live earlier and then
just on the other side of this wall
because this is our real break room are
our bathrooms that were both shut down
immediately uh this is why we're never
in office yeah just as soon as you put
five people
uh vanity bathrooms but they look great
they do gorgeous bathrooms just not
functional they're all furnished by epic
hero
it's all fabric all of it yeah uh yeah
they're weirdly they're like a
spider-man bun as a bathroom actually
speaking of we should uh shout out real
quick uh our merch partners uh with epic
hero but also a new rockstarsmirch.com
zach i like what you talked about yes so
uh you've all been watching maybe inside
marvel some of our other moon knight
coverage we've got a new latest
obsession shirt around built around
inspired by the moon knight series
called tomb of the moon god you see eric
is wearing it breakdowns of moon night
it's a cool shirt it's a limited edition
thing probably only going to be around
for another couple weeks might even be
gone before the end of moon night they
don't there's just a set run of those
when you buy one you can also throw in a
couple bucks and get a shout out that
comes out on inside marvel mtn and eric
will maybe uh read your question and
it'll roll at the bottom also the cool
thing about latest obsession shirts in
addition to being great shirts they
directly help support us at new rock
stars this coke zero
that was purchased
by someone who purchased shout outs
this one's for you i'm pouring it out
for you yeah
yeah yeah so you know any any time hey
you need shirts in your life why not get
one from everyone
[Applause]
if we believe
mark said it wasn't him that killed the
father it was his partner and he didn't
name him the partner so who is that part
i don't think he would ever call his
other identity his partner
i think it has to be bushman and i don't
i don't think we're going to see bushman
now but i think we'll see him later if
they want to put him in something else
but i it's clear that it i don't think
it's jake it can't be who is buschmann
in the country also does he have a
separate name or is it just bushman
robert bush
yeah i i
called him bushman
bush man yeah yeah
george h w bush she's like
um he wanted to go and
this wasn't like the very first issue so
i my mind is kind of foggy on it but he
wanted to go back and he's there just to
steal art basically and
who is now layla's father was in the way
of that so
technically in the issues he shot and
almost killed mark but in this he shot
and killed i guess layla's father in
addition to mark mark said he got shot
right
so i guess they fought bushmen and then
uh in the battle they he got shot we got
a new poll running by the way who killed
layla's father uh you got some options
there jake mark i think uh at buschmann
we're getting lots of names we got raul
bushman bob bush
our favorite water boy uh provides the
water inside of the nexus sarcophagus
uh cool so we do do we do think that uh
we are at least being set up whoever
killed layla's father is a character
that we need to be keeping i think he's
gonna show up later i think there's too
much happening right now especially for
like the second this next episode is
definitely gonna be about how they're
gonna get out of what they're in and
then the last episode will be like
closer so i don't think he's gonna show
up in the last episode well also i'll
just throw this out there only because
like we're two thirds of the way through
this series if we haven't met that
character it feels like a little late to
introduce an important character
definitely a power broker couldn't have
been arthur herrera oh
he's the one that told her to like you
should have remembered the details it
could be a strong stretch strong stretch
it could be ahmed that had another
avatar at the time kill leila's father
because why would arthur harold be like
hey well let's start a fight let's start
oh interesting because like we know
ahmed has been banished by his by her
last avatar did we know when that was
was that modern times or was that in
ancient times
well or you mean was betrayed yes
yeah well one of the questions is is
alexander the great the person who
betrayed um
because he had the thing jumped down his
throat seems like that would be the
avatar but we're also like we don't know
if he she can come out we don't know if
she if there was any little bit like how
did arthur harold learn about her you
know how did he get in trouble and how
did the ushabti get into the real world
if they're if they exist in the overvoid
they're made in the over void that's
where khan's was made because that that
trial that happens in the great pyramid
that uh mar or steven labels that oh
we're in the overboard they're not
actually in the pyramid they're like
overvoid so like
how did that statue get into the real
world
away from the gods and get put there who
did the betraying all this portraying
and i think this maybe got brought up on
a rogue theory or something like that
what if the third personality is ahmed
ahmed is the third personality so you
guys haven't heard this before but we've
been talking about that in the office a
lot the idea that wouldn't it be cool if
it's i mean jake locklear would be great
but wouldn't it be cool if the third
personality was working against mark and
stephen so and that would align with the
fact that suddenly those people were
dead they were trying to get information
out of them but if it's an ahmed
controlled personality or a hero someone
is
allied with him and is actively awaking
ruining things for them and then they
have to fight amongst themselves ooh the
uh the identity commentary there and
stuff you're your own worst enemy like
that well because also why didn't they
release that third sarcophagi right yeah
why is it why is it being shut down yeah
like
there could be a situation where ahmed
doesn't want to be released like ahmed
is fine being locked away because maybe
ahmed has been misused by people like
arthur harrow who wants to use her
powers to take people's souls even when
they haven't even done the bad things
she can choose her own avatar so that
makes me it's like just choose a
different avenue maybe she's got bad
taste in advertising
i was single for a long time because i
kept picking the wrong avatar yeah
avatars means girlfriend tell me about
our other our latest sponsor that brings
me to our latest sponsor expressvpn if
you want to know what i've been getting
up to
you can't i don't know there's no way
for you you can't tell well the chat the
chat poll seems a thing 51 think that
bushman bob
that does make the most sense but yeah i
don't know how we get to that with two
more episodes left well i mean
well what
again another stretch i know this isn't
rogue theory but here i come again um
what if it is a werewolf
whatever it is
one of it is wearable by night also
because again somebody uh nathaniel
becker is saying the same thing oh are
you or well where willings
yes yes nathaniel becca um i because it
it's like that we don't need to have it
be bushman it can be any other villain
so this would set up the way for their
halloween special i say this because
it's not confirmed yet if it is but it
definitely is uh so it could be set up
for that perfectly especially because
one of the identities in the comic books
fights a bunch of space werewolves and
why can't those face werewolves just be
translated to this werewolf down here
that's just going crazy now when when
the cops uh were they had arrested
uh stephen and they were looking up the
file about what he did and they
mentioned that one of them was like had
their hands tied behind their back and
like shot in the back of the head
i assumed that was layla's father they
were that specific one so they catch
also why would a werewolf shoot a guy in
the back of their heads
more efficiently
get away from
i want to call out one of me super chats
brandon because it reminds me something
you said earlier elise just said what if
um alexander the great was rama tut
kang king oh i when this episode was
conqueror of the land and they show that
sarcophagus and it had like lines on its
face i was like oh it's there's going to
be a dead king
has been a ruler of pharaoh
and also we just learned according to
the show alexander the great is kind of
a pharaoh apparently also they said that
uh one of her previous avatars was a
pharaoh i think
uh i don't i don't feel like that was
said at some point of like when i was
betrayed
by aaron eric pointed out in the
breakdown right like um
oh alexander the great maybe he was
ahmed's avatar because like alexander
the great had this cult following
he was able to yeah
he was able to get people to you know
build a giant army to conquer half of
the known world or whatever so like
maybe and all of your hero kind of
building his own army of followers right
maybe kang also has that kind of power
manipulation yeah we get into it in big
question this week but like don't plug
you out
alexander the great loved egypt he was
there for like a year and he loved the
place who caught himself like the son of
zeus almond he wanted he wanted to be
buried in egypt he was like take my body
back to egypt
he was a big egypt stand you know what
so i feel like zach had a point
definitely when he said that it feels a
little late to introduce somebody kind
of like random to add on but if the
person they introduce is jonathan majors
and then it suddenly makes sense why
we're not getting season two of moon
knight because like all this was setting
up you know a kang storyline oh maybe we
got moon knight in loki season two
low key that'd be great uh
and then uh i want to skip ahead to uh
we haven't really faced the major
question head-on of what is going on at
the end there i know we say oh it could
be the overvoid somebody else did the
afterlife but also it's just an asylum
yeah right what about that possibility i
mean obviously maybe the hippo is a uh
you know visualization well it's a
well-funded asylum at least for the
office with a great color sons of
architecture yeah in statues
i mean i guess you could get those at uh
home goods but but like the fact that
he's seen the tv show that is inspiring
the extent of the character the name of
steven uh you know i think that's just
one of his identities
is the the character in that tv show
because steven is a famous actor in the
comics and i think it's like an homage
to that too but i also think that's one
of his identities i wonder if that place
is supposed to represent like mark's
spectre's worst fears like
that he is crazy he's powerless that he
has no power that all of everything
around him can be explained all of his
notions or his what he thinks are real
concerns or or conflicts are all easily
explained away able by this simple mind
prison not mind palace oh
well that also that goes with when
arthur harrow is being the psychiatrist
right he has that great quote about no
tree can go to heaven without its roots
being in hell maybe we're in hell yeah
maybe right now i love that this show
right now yeah well especially that that
white that white uh
we don't have our bathrooms
working what we always say no toilet can
flush down to heaven without it surging
up to hell yeah
uh before we move on to the next thing i
wanna toss the question out to chat you
guys can give us your explanation of
what you think is going on with this
space
overvoid afterlife an actual asylum uh
the
uh those are the main options i guess
you'll sound unusual if you don't pick
those but i would love to hear what your
ideas are go ahead and put them in the
chat uh somebody's gonna be pulling them
aside for us so we can shout out some of
these but while you guys do that i want
to ask you guys literally what how does
he come back from this because he's like
he might be drowning in the water right
now even if he is in his mind or the
overvoid whatever how does he escape
this situation
well don't you think it's important they
run into towerette at the end she's
obviously different we haven't seen any
non-humanoids in this asylum right maybe
she's gonna be their guide to escape
right like maybe she's got some kind of
magic maybe there's some kind of
mcguffin or something someone i think
dalton something made a good point in
the chat that that there are times where
tyler why is it just yeah
albuquerque something
his first name is dalton i forget his
last name but he made a good point that
uh
that the tower is has been associated
with reincarnation in the past as well
okay so she said be helping oh she can
bring it back to life
and then i mean ostensibly layla could
dive in there and try and retrieve him
right i mean like she's in that room
like watching him get shot like she
could save him and brandon i think uh
you have now been uh punished where you
need to be okay replaced uh with your
stats
uh but in the meantime you guys are
saying
how uh he'll get out of here i don't
know what zach is saying
hate words in sign language but uh
he's giving us some real knowledge here
in the chat oh uh chrissy says is that
the pink one is that chrissie
now oh uh tower red is the goddess of
birth and rejuvenation i think that she
got involved because mark died in water
and towered has been linked to the nile
which brings life it's not just the
rejuvenation of health and likelihood
but rejuvenation of the dead external
plane where all gods just are when
they're banished but they can somehow
get back that's her thought since moon
knight won't be gone i thought i didn't
even know that it was linked to the nile
which would make sense yeah this idea of
that water being special is super
interesting but brandon what do you
think well what about kanchu okay like
if konshu gets released from his ushabti
he could ostensibly heal mark bring it
back from the dead mark steven he did it
once before right that was how
mark first got connected got a whole
bunch of guys trapped in new shaktis
how's it how's they can't get out how's
it how's uh
going to get kanchu is he's a fighter
okay he goes against the gods he finds a
way okay he's he's scrappy he he's got
tenacity he's got action in the paint i
don't know uh he just gets it done you
know it sounds like brandon's always
yelling at us i am always yelling at you
all right that's why he's getting built
like thanos yeah look at his body if i
may uh take my hand
oh thank you that's very comforting i
think you make some really good points
here thank you thank you all right and i
think you're doing a really great job i
think i think i'll feel like kanchu is
the one he loves mark stephen
all right oh no there you go the targets
are broken
again
uh uh all right so uh what are some uh
other predictions people had what if
mark and stephen are variants and
somehow when mark died he popped into
stephen and now since stephen died there
in another place or maybe where a
different variant is maybe a different
multiverse or dimension that's from low
that's an interesting take uh wildflower
thinks uh definitely overvoid and uh
tower red will be uh the way out uh and
hey what do you know we actually hit our
uh ultimate super chat goal where
everyone is punished by having to uh uh
so we'll throw up a be right back screen
real quick
well we all oh
all right johnny got that oh it's just
starting soon but we're still here we're
still here don't panic
oh okay oh god it hurts why did it
always hurt uh did i lose my mic it's
painful to be turned into statutes oh
gosh i haven't read it magic is real uh
um mine i have trouble standing
i believe in magic
in a young girl's heart yeah so uh yeah
oh gosh okay
okay well this this makes for thrilling
streaming guys
where are they
uh where are the zach what are you
saying oh well i was just gonna call out
a silhouette edited animator uh in the
chat thank you for the super chat what's
the last thing you remember that's what
mark said to steven in the hospital i
feel like they were definitely
referencing legion okay so there's clues
and parallels legion on fx if you saw
that uh
set you know in
largely in an asylum type of situation
with a kind of mentally unstable uh
mutant in that case um it'd be an
interesting thing that's kind of a
cross-platform
reference that would be like referencing
something in the spider-verse or
something like that but i i i see you
nice
uh uh we're also great at this um can we
get here from somebody else can we hear
from somebody else
oh are we asking you are we answering
all the questions oh just uh just your
thoughts how about this uh who uh who's
gonna be the person that lets uh
whoever's in there and the sarcophagus
out is that someone that mark and steven
want to let out i don't think it's going
to get out oh i think it was just like a
clear like example of like there's more
than one person in here like you gotta
see a third personality right
the thing is i remember them writing and
like
in like a piece i can't even remember if
it was on screen rant or somewhere that
they were just like we can't force
everybody in here that's why we haven't
seen frenchie yet that's why we haven't
seen like they're like we can give
homages but we there's just too many
characters
in moon knight to like have to approach
especially with like his identity it
would be interesting if because they
have not
said this is a limited series right
they're not gonna make another moon
knight as far as we know yeah if he's
just gonna get folded into the main mcu
if a lot of this is all not real just
and moon knight's the only real thing
that's left and that gets brought into
the mcu and none of these other
characters get brought back over i don't
know it would be a little interesting i
think this is a good a good little chat
that someone put in the chat that was
something that john brought up that i
think is great to mention is that their
sarcophagus are different like jake's oh
not jigsaw it's not jake uh
marks no stevens sarcophagus was much
lighter than the third one that we saw i
don't know the uh significance in that
but
hey
i'm back in the flesh uh
i i like that the fact that there must
be some significance to the
circumference guy right we maybe don't
know it yet until we know that it
doesn't care whether you're speaking
yeah how do you apologize i apologize uh
jessica kisses you
somebody else in the in the chat behind
the camera
[Applause]
it took us seven hours in the office to
figure out this bit okay
and i would say uh
unequivocally it was a hit
my favorite uh chat question was how
long has this bit
as long as it takes uh there was there
was a great super chat um what's the
significance of the kiss between stephen
and
i got to weigh in on this because i said
this earlier and i got shocks and groans
i felt like layla
i was acting funny from the moment they
got near the the tomb uh i felt like her
personality changed a little bit she was
being a little more like affectionate
and like kind of lovey-dovey towards
steven which doesn't make a ton of sense
to me because marcus her husband
unless she's trying to make mark jealous
unless she has an agenda to try and pry
mark out because she is more than what
we've seen so far i thought the kiss was
kind of out of character for her to kiss
the other personality of her husband's
like they're they're clearly two
different things like it's not like
kissing mark even though it is the same
body it's like two very different
personalities shockingly her husband is
so long that it's probably like this is
my husband he smells like my husband i'm
just like enamored with my husband yeah
but they saw each other before remember
they were sitting at that restaurant
they've had they've been around each
other long enough for if she wanted to
jump his bones she would have done it i
think the privacy of their own home it
was the heat of the moment
i think that that the only reason i see
mostly i think tommy might be projecting
about whenever he sees romance he
doesn't buy it in life but uh just
because you hate it but the reason why i
think that he might be honest something
is didn't it feel a little like almost
cheesy yeah they were kissing where was
kind of like really this and then right
after that we see oh it's all happening
in his head like almost like he was
doing wish fulfillment in that moment
and then i get the girl
that makes me think that it's happening
in stephen's head not necessarily in my
head
that would not be mark's fantasy that
some other guy yeah we don't know maybe
mark is a cuckold
and
[Applause]
i don't know i think to mark that was
all gucci to moochie
steven's manifestation of layla in the
asylum is she's stealing from him and
like steals the bingo from him and is
like oh i'm i'm going to take the winner
i'm the winner
well and
correct me it's mark that gets shot or
is it did the personality revert back i
think again right before it goes
with the thing yeah which does seem like
market
he got caught like it seems like strange
for him to get caught that way like he
looks like a very smart we know one
thing about that there's too many people
he's always getting shot
he loves getting a shot he actually does
isn't that what triggered consu to save
mark initially was mark
in a moment of death right having just
been shot it's about to happen again in
some way if mark's the one who's in
charge of the body when it's shot and
falls through the water is this mark's
asylum or is
i think it's this steven's
because people's coming but mark is the
one that's freed right right now because
we're following mark mark discovers
stephen yeah mark let's stephen out so
like all that wheelchair stuff all that
talking to hero that's all mark right
yeah also i wanted i wanted to know when
you were talking about layla and the uh
the ward her band-aid has the scarab
yeah the right and so i was like i
there's just too much leaning to like
she means a lot
i'm like this is a very very very
important game the fortress said like
the her dad called her the yeah her
little scarab or whatever and then
she's a god jess exactly i was about to
say his pitch before that she's secretly
a god and has been and she needs to be
awakened i think she i i
me and michael jordan so
i think she just especially when he
yells wake up i'm like okay that's rude
the first stop and then secondly it must
mean something he has kept his notes at
an indoor voice this entire time and
then out of nowhere he just screams wake
up and i'm like is it because he needs
what if layla's on it okay you know what
uh
speaking of questions i want we'll have
one more question for you guys but then
we're going to go ahead and go to our q
a of uh the super chats we've collected
if we can start um putting those up on
our screen uh we'll try to hit as many
of your super chat questions you guys
have you have some more you can drop
them right now but my last question is
what the
hippo uh is the creature or the
creatures that were inside of the tomb
what are those
what are they called well they there's
the there was this egyptian sorcerer
known as hecka knight who's involved
these four elements that are like the
things of creation which are like as
strong as infinity stones
heck and that was like a sorcerer these
these are have been referred to as like
heck of priests
uh these kind of like magic imbued
priests because you don't want to say
hell
for holy people yeah he's a hecka priest
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a great
kind of breeze that's a priest but it
does seem like these were put there to
prevent people from getting to ahmed's
uh
right so did that i forget the name of
the mage who made the star chart
food mcfarland sefu mcfarland uh great
great artist on smartphones
uh uh he
he he i guess he maybe put them there to
guard on they seem to be there to stop
people from releasing um
i think that ties to uh
like that there's there's various gods
that are being
pushed down and held out including
konchu it's almost like the enyad
actually has a secret plan that they're
trying to like keep these other gods out
as discussed on a previous episode of
that's true that's true are you talking
about the creatures that was like
climbing the wall yeah the ones that
like attack
oh okay they have no eyes they have no
suffocation yeah so then what what does
that mean i guess i'm more because it
was like if they're there to protect
ahmet and then they're like literally
uh taking the organs out they're
mummifying another human are they doing
it to
worship on that or
because it's a random person it's not
like uh yeah they they don't know what
else to that's what they've done there
that's why
i said don't do what you know
i bring that up all the time c-sections
are crazy they pull out all the organs
and they put them all back
usually bearded men don't get c-sections
you know
come on that's uh you're not woken up
for me why are you talking
that we saw when they first get to the
two before they go in outside we see
harrow's camp there's they don't see it
but we the audience see blood we see one
of the tools so like these things came
out of the tomb once they realized that
these guys were there to come in i guess
and like started pulling people down you
know that the heck of priests if that
was if that's what they are they're
attacking they're both attacking you
know layla and mark slash stephen but
also a lot of
heroes man right so they don't like any
intruders right what's happened again
well i'll go ahead and uh intro uh the
final segment we're doing as i get
punished uh maybe somebody brandon you
always get upset can you
put me in a uh yeah
all right so for this last bit we're
going to go ahead and go to your guys's
uh
hold on slow down okay hold on oh it's
not funny take it easy
i'm just laughing i love it
um
tommy uh we do this all the time now let
me introduce a segment it's going to be
just a q a of our super chats so if we
can get uh those super chat questions uh
up on our notes okay i i see one from uh
lane prevalent i suspect in order to be
freed from their statue the statue has
to be broken pretty sure mark put the
emmett statue in his back pocket when
harrow came in so do you think like hey
maybe his death might have broken that
statue releasing her and is it that
simple yeah all you have to do is break
the statue boys they're watching her i
think they're watching him so closely
under guard right now because the
statue's not broken yet and they're like
don't move too much i don't think the
statue's broken yet but we also need to
recognize that the statue got taken out
of the mouth of uh
alexander the great yes so i got taken
out of his mouth so i think that meant
something like oh we're almost there not
fully broken yet all right that's what i
mean another good question from voodoo's
man forever uh
uh with two episodes can we safely rule
out that uh blade will show up there's a
lot of theorizing that blade might jump
i don't think blade would show up well
hey
you didn't think he was going to show up
in the turtles and he didn't no they
snuck him in the boy the voice of blade
show okay well that's a
i mean
uh we'll probably get a post credit
scene in this series right that might be
a nice spot to have somebody i hope it's
just a voice again
we're putting together a team
together
a thing that i'm curious about your
opinion on here uh could bushman be the
third personality i would love for
bushman to be the third personality but
i don't think it's
i don't like him being like oh it was my
partner that killed someone and he's
still referring to his identity as a
partner i don't think he marches yeah he
would have to be aware of it right yeah
i would like i want bushman to actually
be one of the gods if anything i just
want him to be a god so bob bushman
but i think it's a good idea uh mesh
labs asked what if steven thought he
blipped but really marker jake was in
control for a few years where did these
endless pits and pools lead to that's
technically too he's snuck in two of
them
i don't know i i i think the the pool
being so deep might have been a it's
like a that's a musical thing because
like he hits the water and his face is
still above the water like maybe it's
about deep or whatever right but then
yeah uh
that's interesting um we got somebody
saying uh oh olivia adams can we have a
moment of silence for gus disgusting
goldfish gus is a goldfish
the short flipper gus is gone right but
also uh mark and stephen have been in
egypt foreign
was that what it was they just didn't
get fed and that's why it died well
let's either way let's acknowledge its
death with a quick moment of silence
dead air as we call it for gus
[Music]
don't release your goldfish in the wild
if you're out there also they're not
they're an invasive species they usually
grow very big and take over lakes it's
very dangerous if you want more
catfishes eating up on tearing down our
ecosystem just remember spay and neuter
your
goldfish yeah always always make sure
your goldfish are fixed uh fish on a
bike asks do you
have a bike do you all think they'll
find other guns that have been trapped
in ooh shouties in the asylum also hey
jessica from the pacific
yeah like maybe that there are a lot of
people or gods are being held there for
some reason i think right i also think
like if there is a higher god
this started off really well for us
you know i question it sometimes because
why does he let bad channels on youtube
what are we doing here
so i think if there is a higher god he
is forcing them to stay in the overvoid
i think that it's like i if all the gods
are using their powers to put them into
little um
or chapters yes
little shorties then i think it's like
there has to be a more powerful one that
can just keep you guys there i feel like
you're able to leave you can leave if
you're powerful enough and i also think
you're you can leave if you have an
avatar so those that don't have avatars
are kind of just like i'm stuck here
are you somehow setting up gore the god
butcher or zeus or something right that
there's a whole level of gods above the
egyptian gods dalton mitchell
dalton mitchell you all laughed at me is
he related
to something by first name dalton he's
the one that made the excellent point
about tolerate being sometimes revered
as the goddess of reincarnation oh okay
so you know what guys i know that that
was 12 minutes ago
go back to it i'm glad we circled back
to it
put that in your pipe and cram it down
your throat
i love going
it's going to go back to god
i don't know to be fair we didn't go
back to 12 minutes ago
so you guys were so cruel to me and
every once in a while i got to make sure
everything's gucci with moochie you know
what i'm saying the one above all
earlier we established that it means to
murder someone i think to get mooched uh
uh but the one above all
is
maybe i don't think it's gore i think or
not gore but but certainly is there a
level like you're saying above the
egyptian gods and they're being
trapped wanted it to be osiris but it's
definitely not osiris his avatar is a
little too i mean all the celestials are
above the gods any god are they they are
this has been established in the comics
plenty of times because being at comics
comics comics this
[Applause]
of avengers or thanos in this show right
there has been references to thanos but
no there's the grc they they haven't had
the global repatriation oh yeah yeah
wouldn't this be an argument for the
fact that none of this is really
happening yeah it could be something
he's bringing in from the real world
into his like fantasy or is this another
reality where there's a grc for another
cause another catastrophe
maybe kang maybe someone else came in
laid waste to the earth and we lost a
bunch of people maybe not through a blip
but through a snap or through a a bang
golf club i thought you were going to
say that
i thought you were going to say a snack
and i was like
everybody snacked
on poison sub-zero visuals layla may be
the key to releasing on that
i want
now when you mentioned her dad calling
her the little scarab i'm like she is
the schedule well and
think about right hero the the compass
is leading him to the tomb by the time
he actually gets to the tomb who's in
that room
what if they got there
would have opened until later
stung me with a thousand bees
um well we're about out of time
yeah uh oh just me all right well it's
been nice getting to hang with you guys
let's get phillip out of here then we
can finish up our videos let's bring
dalton and uh
mitchell my guy okay
or whoever you are dalton if you exist
uh okay uh let's give uh uh thank you to
the chat for showing up here for this
little experiment yeah uh that we did
obviously we did not tell anybody that
we would do it we're doing this it's
illegal for us to take the air like this
and now we have to give equal time to
our competition unfortunately uh richard
nixon uh but uh anything to shout out
you guys yeah i want to thank everyone
for contributing again all these funds
will go to my legal defense fund as
always
and we just appreciate you guys
contributing anything you can do you
know just chip in and we're going to get
this all put behind us in the new year
by 2025 i should be you have like this
envelope of expunged records that then
keeps getting expired it's like a
russian nesting doll of crimes
but but truly this is something we want
to do more of we did something for
spider-man no way home back in december
uh maybe hopefully it's something we can
do more of in the future and we
appreciate getting a nice response from
folks like yourself certainly uh
encourages us to do a little bit more
big reminder this doesn't replace
anything else that we're doing you can
probably see that this channel has never
made more content than it has right now
in fact that's one good reason eric's
not here eric has to still keep pumping
out all the eric videos because we don't
want to take those away from you right
so yeah we can't give him a breath of
frustration
to seven computers pumping information
out of him he's drawing out his life
he's like the creature at the end of the
stranger things trailer yeah yeah we
matrixed him yes
but thank you so much thank you to uh on
screen uh producer john and dodson for
helping us put this together and uh
people in the chat that have helped
explain where eric is or also uh deleted
hate words uh the two most important
things that i are taught to
check out new rockstarsmarch.com
follow us on twitter yeah all of us are
lulu underscore clemens and a brand new
thing this is actually we're kind of
debuting this knowledge right now new
rockstars is now on tumblr
we just heard about it
just now i mean literally we're on
tumblr as of yesterday but we're going
to be posting regularly specifically
we're going to be posting a lot of moon
night content on tumblr it's a fun
platform it kind of gives us some
different opportunities to do some
different kind of content hey if you're
a tumblr user hop on there if you used
to use tumblr get on there
charlie
all right uh uh and with that our god
damn it
we're out bye
[Music]